and so i said do you think it's possible  that you want to go to college because  it's a it's a it's a socially acceptable  shield for you not being successful in  entrepreneurship  do you think do you think that that  might be a reason because if you're in  college then  you you're not seen as a failure if  you're not  winning at the thing that you're doing  right it's your side hustle it's your  side gig  he's like well maybe yeah  and  i think first off you know kudos to him  for being able to realize and admit that  but i think that that was is such a core  issue for many of us  is that  we present these socially acceptable  solutions to ourselves when deep down  the reason that we're doing them is not  for the right reason and so in this  instance he's using it as a foil to  protect himself against having to  confront the realities of life of  business of the marketplace of not being  good enough right yet